I believe in having your own residence
too if you can afford it that you should
not live with your partner if you can if
you can afford it because it weakens the
polarity that's the number one thing
um if you can't afford it that you
that's if you're dating obviously when
you get married no no no no in marriage
as well what you should not live with
each other no you don't think that a
husband wife should live together what
about with kids okay and and Alex I'll
dress up at all again I'm speaking yes
I'm speaking extremes but and couples do
modify but you'd be surprised ask some
Realtors now what homes are selling and
what homes people want they want them
with separate bedrooms and separate
bathrooms okay but that's okay but
they're in the same home okay separate
bathrooms
here's the reason why the reason why is
it's very simple and then you have to
see and look and see what's working now
if it's 50 we know all the stats on
marriage we don't need to go over there
so obviously what we're doing now is not
working now the tantric perspective is
all about polarity that's what I teach
so polarity weakens because everyone
sits at home in Netflix and chills
when you do that over time that charge
isn't there anymore and you don't want
to [ __ ] your wife you don't want to [ __ ]
your husband and that splits up
marriages so my not my concept the
concept that I teach and live by is that
the more you're actually away from each
other the more you come together it's
actual conscious time together where the
man is present with you you're not
working business deals and I'm in the
same room and we're calling that
spending time no you're like with me
right your phone your iPad's put down I
you know I satisfy your sexual needs you
hold me you cuddle we love we connect we
do all that stuff together that's
quality time when you come into my space
you feel my feminine energy is charged
and when I come into your space I feel
the same but is if a man is working all
day yes and you guys live in the same
home when he comes home wouldn't you say
that's like enough space I mean it even
if you have like separate rooms I get
getting ready to like I'm not opposed I
mean I'm saying the extreme is sit for
separate houses but at least separate
rooms where but you're not spending
every night together because what
happens is in the same bed so what
happens is at night you know about like
your chakras and your bodies you have
five different bodies your energy bodies
actually connect and merge at night and
then it weakens the polarity you notice
like your grandparents or you know like
people have been married a long time
they start looking like one another and
they're like oh this is my best friend I
guarantee you they're not [ __ ] right
yeah well they're 80 years old
by the way the real fun fact the highest
age bracket of STDs is like 60 nursing
homes
here here look I know that a lot of
times a lot of what you say is
ideological not necessarily realistic
yeah here's what I will say is realistic
because I don't know many couples are
gonna have separate homes or even
separate bedrooms I'm saying many I I am
sure spend nights at a time but even
Victoria he was like what separate
bathrooms that's nice here's what I I
recommend and I did this yeah
um the girl that I was with for a long
time
um we had it was uh like the main Master
Suite bathroom okay in a in a loft and
then there's like a second smaller
bathroom what have you
um and what I realized was if we were
getting ready in the same bathroom to go
like on a date or out and I saw her
putting the dress on makeup and the saw
her putting the makeup on and you know
it's like
it wasn't as appealing as listen I'm
gonna go I'm gonna use the downstairs
bedroom a bathroom you do your thing
upstairs I'll obviously already an hour
before you I'm just gonna go I'll have a
drink I'll be sitting down but when she
comes down the stairs and I see the
final product I'm like
we love it we don't even need to go yeah
stay in the goddamn house correct it's
because the guy you know I don't want to
see the process of the whole situation
that's polarity what's your feeling is
that and that's what happens when you
live together you sleep together yeah
together you get ready it's too much so
I know what I'm saying is Extreme yeah
but what I tell my girls that are living
together at least take one or two nights
where you don't maybe you don't sleep
together maybe especially if you're
traveling a lot of men who travel you
don't want that I like the cuddles
eventually the cuddling leads to just
being best friends and not that you want
your man to want to [ __ ] you it's true
you want him and the men member men are
visual and they need to be excited men
don't care about cuddling they do and
unless they're more beta the more
they'll wanna I do care about cuddling
after after sex because right
but it's not like high priority you're
not like God I can't wait no you're on
to something here is that because I've
been in relationships that you just get
too comfortable you get too comfortable
we go to bed it's like you know like she
puts a pimple cream on like I'm wearing
my glasses like sleep tape it's like
there's nothing sexy about two people
that are just but if it's like all right
we're gonna be in that bedroom whatever
and then you know bang bang you know
maybe cut whatever like I do get that
there's again moderation balance
moderation if you're spending the same
from the same bathroom getting ready
same bedroom every single time same same
same same working all this it's gonna
get stayed and that's exactly what
you're saying atrophy it's the law of
the Universe I don't make the rules I
just tell you ways that you can biohack
the system people don't just like it
because they're like well I want to be
close every minute of the day well great
but it's not going to work in the end
just look at the stats the numbers don't
lie so if you like that clip click right
here to watch another or if you want to
watch the entire saucecast click right
here
[Music]